lunettes de soleil sorti écouteurs dans
les oreilles les 80 participants au
tournoi magnifique line 2017 sont prêts
à enchaîner 24 heures deux parties de
poker l'endurance 1 jouent un rôle
important parce que c'était une période
de mou vraiment sur ces heures de jeu
quand tu te fais prendre des jetons tout
simplement
il existe une variante qui a été fait
sur cette organisation là si tu peux le
faire à deux en fait joué en duo
tu te partage un peu le supplice 24
heures de jeu de difficultés mais
surtout de solidarité puisque en plus de
se retrouver entre amis les participants
jouent pour cette deuxième édition en
faveur d'une association pour
l'association caritative on a pris donc
vivre au village
c'est une petite association de magny
les hameaux qui s'occupent d'un petit
village en afrique et sont vraiment
super ils nous font des repas magnifique
l'association vivre au village
solidarité nord-sud est une association
à but humanitaire et dead au
développement de magny les hameaux
elle a pour vocation de soutenir des
projets de développement rural dans les
pays du tiers monde
le projet là concrets pour 2018 c'est
l'électrification que dans une école à
d'icônes hop au cameroun qui
e
nécessite un budget d'environ 6000 euros
c'est une électrification par panneaux
solaires donc complètement autonome sur
la région près 24 heures en temps sur
les tables de poker c'est thomas baileys
alias coop qui remporte le tournoi
l'association récolte quant à elle près
de 1400 euros